Jeremy renner's latest update as fans
Jaws on the floor how many bones did he
break in his accident whatever you think
it's more fans of Jeremy Renner have
been eagerly waiting for updates
regarding his disastrous snowplow
accident and it seems like the more we
learn about it the more astounding it is
that he is still in one piece Renner is
out of the hospital now but the injury
could accurately be described as
life-threatening and it seems clear that
he is still on the road to what we all
hope will be a full recovery since being
able to make posts on her social media
accounts the actor has been sure to
thank his fans for their support after
his accident and his latest update is no
different it does also include a new I'd
widening detail that goes to illustrate
further just how serious his injuries
are despite the gravity of the situation
though this latest update also shows
that Rena is maintaining a very positive
attitude something that will most likely
help him in his efforts to recover from
the injury and eventually get back to
his normal life and work the posting
question comes from Jeremy renner's
official Twitter account where Hawkeye
himself gave fans an update on his scary
mishap along with a photo of himself
receiving Medical Care he wrote I want
to thank everyone for their messages and
thoughtfulness much love and
appreciation to you all these 30 plus
broken bones will mend grow stronger
just like the love and bond with family
and friends deepens that's an incredibly
inspiring attitude for someone with
dozens of broken bones and it's good
news for everybody who wants to see
runner on the mend while it remains to
be seen just how long it takes Renault
to heal from his injuries the star has
tons of his friends rooting for him
fellow Marvel Studios co-star Chris
Evans tweeted following Raiders update
that's one tough mother
has anyone even checked on the snow cat
the Hawkeye actor cheekily responded
saying love you brother I did check on
the snow cat she needs fuel meanwhile on
Instagram Chris Hemsworth called his
Avengers endgame co-star a quote
Champion praising his recovery Guardians
of the Galaxy director James Gunn
Aquaman star Jason Momoa and model Heidi
Klum with just a few of the other
celebrities and colleagues at Rena
received love from on Instagram as to
her locker star continues to receive
love and courage from his fans and
colleagues some are curious to know what
the future has in store for the
oscar-nominated actor for now there are
new episodes of the mayor of Kingstown
to look forward to on Sunday nights on
Paramount plus the Taylor Sheridan
series recently got a poster update
after renner's real life injuries Rena
also has two upcoming projects listed on
IMDb one an entitled Oxycontin project
and the other a rumored appearance as a
Marvel Cinematic universe's resident
archer in Avengers the Kang Dynasty
which is slated for release in 2020 E5
what are you doing here disappointing my
kids of course his supposed Avengers
return should be taken with a grain of
salt it also remains to be seen if Rana
will once again team up with Haley
Steinfeld for a second season of Hawkeye
should the actor return as Hawkeye one
can only hope that runner's injuries
will be but a distant memory
[Music]